demonstrates as an Iran pushback against
authorities in mashhad protesting the
death of Masa amini
angry crowds confronted Security forces
in several cities
in the capital to haran protesters have
called for an end to discrimination
against women
amini had been visiting Tehran with her
brother police say she was arrested for
dressing him properly
she collapsed in custody and died
several days later in hospital
her family say she was beaten and that
before the arrest she was fit and had no
health issues the morality police have
denied reports of beating and
mistreatment saying she died of natural
causes the UN has called for an
independent investigation compulsory
veiling laws remain of concern in Iran
where appearing in public without a
hijab is punishable by imprisonment in
recent months the so-called morality
police have expanded Street patrols
subjecting women perceived to be wearing
loose hijab to verbal and physical
harassment and arrest
Iran's law requiring women to wear
headscarves in public dates from the
1979 Revolution but there have been
calls to make it voluntary
in the past few days some have been
burning their veils
for many years I think people have lost
their trust into the government so maybe
they have no hope at what's going to
happen what's going to be the outcome
Iran's supreme leader didn't address the
protest during a speech on Wednesday
Bart State media report that his aide
visited amini's family and promised to
investigate fully
amini was from the province of Kurdistan
in Western Iran where three people were
allegedly killed on Monday during
protests
the 22 year old's funeral was held in
her hometown a long way from where she
died
now Iran's opposition wants to make her
a symbol of the fight for women's rights
Al Jazeera